palmira palm sugar doesn't come out of
the palm IRA palm tree looking like this
from harvesting to processing there are
many steps between the tree and the
ultimate product the tree produces the
round fruit seen on the right and the
cylindrical flower cluster on the left a
palm sugar harvester prepares
specialized containers for harvesting
the SAP by threading twine through a
hole near the rim these tubes are made
from bamboo and in Thailand they're
called crabbit mypie the harvester adds
wood chips to the tubes the wood chips
come from the shariah tree which is
called pi um in Thailand the chips will
help prevent the sap from fermenting
some Palmyra trees are more than 100
years old
here the harvester climbs a ladder that
reaches up around 66 feet at the top of
the tree
the harvester uses a machete to cut the
tip off the palm IRA flowers where
they've been cut the flowers exude drops
of SAP which will collect in the bamboo
tubes he brings the SAP he's collected
to an outdoor stove
the harvester prepares a basket covered
with several layers of gauze to filter
the liquid he then slowly and carefully
pours the SAP through the filters into
the wok below the harvesting stage is
complete production now begins the
filtered sap now boils away in the wok
for approximately 45 minutes as it
thickens into a sugar after roughly 30
minutes the SAP begins to turn white the
worker removes the pan from the heat
source it's ready for the next phase on
its path to becoming sugar although it's
often referred to as palm sugar it's
also known as jaggery the worker now
uses a custom-made whisking tool to
thoroughly mix the jaggery shaped like a
large spring the whisk helps cool the
sugar while mixing it finally the sugar
cools and dries to a thick flaky texture
ready to be packaged and shipped around
the world